нижня палата парламенту нідерландів
з хвалила законопроект на рахунку ратифікацію
воду про асоціацію україною з
тепер слово за верхню палату професор
амстердамського університету марк янсен
Перикон на ще голосування будете
пісня виборі до нижньої палати
парламенту і кіпр і значення на 15
березня
вас не проблема вона поливаю в тому шукаю
маячні партії на благання 6 вуса знайти
їсти треба бути я petrenko нижчих партій
на радіо треба мовляв з дому партіям і
цілей не і леви прибирали хвата wintoflash
волосся вати за асоціацію з україною
проте ще потрібне волосся їх може
треба ти християнські демократи вуса знайти
е християнські демократи які за відведення
просвітять більше сенатори у спарті
християнських демократів та про
європейськими
занепала їх не партія в цілому у
проголосувало у нижній палаті про ти за
словами експерта все закласти вигляд
партійної дисципліни та проголосуйте
крім сина туру за воду в рази cool і
партія проти результати вибору у до
нижньої палати у б різанини можете полону ти
на розміщення політичних сил
зраду акценту та шансу у тата ліску
партії свободи вілдерса показали високі
результати на виборах та nights to the
nai пак його партії люк парламенті
я хочу популісти забудуть високу спить
ринку
а про європейську партію витрачати то це
може за хвилину позицію християнських
демократій то диван може подумати ще
на так доброго у свата за кут ду
я все ж таки на там є популісти чекаю буду
стиль отримавши стиль кінчику йти про
партіях і заїзд здайся краще якщо так
то пак йому вірність щоб на
проголосує за угоду
[музика]
що дозволяють нам він виплив популісти
вислови победи
але ж на консервативній партії експорт
зам страда мск університету перука вона на
європе фікації сенатом біля води про
асоціацію
україною з